[Applause]
foreign
happy Wednesday everyone tonight I want
to take a trip across the pond to a
place called the UK it used to stand for
United Kingdom but now it stands for
unhinged knuckleheads
feeble-minded freaks called just stop
oil after seeing them you'd wish they'd
just stopped breathing
you've seen their protest they blocked
traffic during rush hour which makes
them as persuasive as Alec Baldwin
teaching gun safety
because nothing inspires societal change
better than acting like a total
but last week when they pulled a traffic
stunt this happened
[Music]
yeah nothing like a plotting violence
I agree a furious motorist steps in to
remove the blockade but did the police
side with the working class guy the
productive member of society was just
trying to get to his job or the
shiftless imbeciles who have been laid
since the Thatcher era watch
[Music]
oh
yeah
it's amazing the police cuffed the
motorist perhaps because he just doesn't
have the right politics that would allow
him to break the law if only he were a
drag queen racing to the library to read
to orphans
but we see this more and more here's the
hierarchy the protesters who have all
the time in the world yet know where to
get to are allowed to break the law and
impede your life and the guy who steps
in because the cops won't well he's the
thug so a mob of idiots get legal
protection and if you do something about
it the cops will detain you it's as if
the country is run by a family of
inbreds
well played thank you well played
history tree don't Fork so the problem's
obvious we're supposed to calculate the
amount of suffering that goes into
harming a protester but you can't do the
same for the suffering caused by the
protesters people who Miss job
interviews or need to go to a doctor's
appointment or need to see a specialist
about excessive back hair
meanwhile there's another Bridge oh
you're gonna love this an 18 year old
named mizzy from London who films
himself doing actual crimes so it's like
Hunter Biden but with pants
for example here's the delightful chap
stealing a woman's dog in a park
hello hi you got a nice dog
how are you we're going on stoke
outside
yeah did I mention he also likes to walk
into strangers homes
James
[Music]
is this where the study group is
this no
um
all right
this is nobody study we got kids man oh
you got kids
wow great prank try that in Texas and
he'd have more holes in him than a
centipedes bowling ball
he also harasses women telling them
they're gonna die
from over there I like your hair still
that's a nice hair
it's not something luscious I'm
perfectly fine we're gonna die
had to top it off he menaces Jews
I mean what's he trying to do audition
for MSNBC
now Missy claims he's just a Merry
Prankster trying to be noticed but with
that logic Jeffrey Dahmer was just
auditioning for a spot on Top Chef
but after two weeks of terrorizing
people he's finally arrested but frankly
rust moves faster and so what's his
defense well they're pranks you know the
same way stopping traffic is a protest
he also adds quote I'm a black male
that's why there's such an uproar which
really means he assumed he could get
away with it because he was a black male
in technical terms it's called
smolititis
but I don't blame him for thinking he's
Above the Law because so many people are
those protesters are and let's not
forget that we saw over 100 days of
riots lootings assaults 2 billion in
Damages up to 40 people killed torched
precincts and courthouses but we saw no
Mass arrests or mass convictions so many
people are above the law and it's all
because we excuse insanity and now you
can do anything because you're fighting
oppression even when there is no
oppression around
like the people blocking traffic they
win because those hard-working people in
cars are evil and if one of those
drivers accidentally hits a protester
well you know who what the villain would
be even if the protester put his own
life in danger and imagine if someone
shot that teen when he broke into his
house who would be the villain then even
if that punk had put his own life in
danger you and I know so that's where we
are it's a moral flip where cops cuff a
regular Joe protesters get protection
and criminals who filmed their exploits
gain infamy until the public steps in
it's already happened here with Daniel
Penny Penny saw some nut on the subway
threatening innocent people and he
stepped in because nobody else would now
Penny's been charged with manslaughter
for doing the cops job just like that
motorist did the cop's job I'm guessing
you're going to see more of this people
doing the cops job
fact is activists and criminals alike
exploited their human prey for being
mostly peaceful we're nice people but we
are finally seeing what happens when you
push these nice people too far and the
responses vigilantism or is it public
service
at this point who knows it's just a
necessity
[Applause]
it's her more than crosses in sunlight
Florida congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna
his fans line up for tickets to Belgium
to be euthanized after a writer and
comedian Jamie listow
like a bent sewing machine
she seems weird
oh yeah that's good
I'm embarrassed that came out of my
mouth
and I don't say that very often yeah
that was cat Tint by the way hi
oh boy
and finally he moonlights as a cell
tower my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
Jamie uh you welcome protesters at your
show cause at least somebody's there
um
yeah if you don't read the signs it's
like Yep they're there for me yes
um what do you make of like the fact
that those cops took the the pro the guy
trying to do their job down I thought
that was just outrageous it was
infuriating right it was infuriating I
will say though of all the protests did
you see the the just stop oil which I
don't like the name of their I feel like
they're like just stop oil
um they can be more powerful you know um
do you know it was a slow walk
that was what the protest was was a slow
walk right which if that if you're doing
it to me you can have whatever you want
like if they're starting to pick things
that are that annoying like I think all
the people in Times Square today are
also protesting the same thing yes Ross
and I'm like What's Next are they gonna
like shoot really loud
because that's also I have a I have a
weird thing where I can't yeah is this
just me where I can't like I saw someone
someone's eating a peach once right next
to me I was like if this guy takes
another bite another juicy loud bite of
this Peach I'm going to prison today
and then he was like oh you must have
misophonia yeah I was like what's that
and he goes well that's when you get
annoyed like really annoyed at other
people chewing and I was like that's
possible or maybe you have eat like an
animal's disease there's nothing wrong
with me but can I say one quick thing
about um you never say one quick thing
that's true could I see one slow drawn
out set up followed by a short on funny
punchline
please do the mizzy thing is really
upset like the thing with the old woman
I I hate this guy I hate him so much and
it's like are these really pranks
they're not like he's getting into the
wrong Uber he's going into his are these
pranks or just things that Biden will do
next week yes
ending on a high note and some red meat
uh representative Luna welcome to the
show very happy to be here excellent
excellent what do you make of that this
idea that like basically now the society
is because it's seen as oppressed has
fewer rights to the people who are
claiming that they are oppressed I mean
the fact is is that this guy is
obviously monetizing his platform on
harassing normal citizens but it's crazy
because this doesn't just stop in the
culture War it's bleeding over and we
see it every day in politics and every
single day we hear people that say you
know the um the most marginalized
Community when we are born in the
greatest country in the world is seeming
to struggle the most yeah if you put in
the hard work and effort you can
accomplish anything so I'm not surprised
it's frustrating but someone like this I
mean obviously get the guy's a criminal
and he's clearly harassing people yeah
all right you know uh Tyrus I just keep
thinking what you would do
you would do in either of these
situations
sometimes I'll float over into the
traffic situation and I'll fantasize
I'll fantasize and it could go that
though fantasy could go on for days and
then I go back to the the guy wandering
in with his friends in your house if he
would just come to my house and be so
happy
I would probably say somebody finally
got me a gift that I wanted yeah
kids did you do this for me you get to
see Daddy be a monster for a little
while uh the only and I loved your
monologue but you you know the whole
thing about holes in them though it's
Texas it'd just be one hole no that's
just be one hole quarters
before they just get wild with him
here's the thing he's and it's always
the it drives me crazy it seems to be
the thing right now uh they're only
doing this because I'm black no they're
doing this because you're stealing and
videotaping it breaking into people's
house the the caveat is that you're
black now that you're caught it's
because you're breaking crimes but it
goes back to first world problems we
live in America it's a beautiful first
world place where you can claim that
that's not happening you can not even
have creative slogans stop the oil yeah
and they drew a skeleton on it I don't
know what bones and oil have to do with
each other other than the dinosaurs you
know what I'm saying but they just do
and the reason why the police arrested
the guy is because he put hands on them
but so as long as he didn't put hands up
I was a little little shocked I don't
understand why he got out of his car and
pushed them when he could have done the
same thing in his car and done it
hands-free
because here's the deal I don't care how
dedicated you are a moving car you'll
move yes you can be slow it can be like
Austin Powers or the guy's like no oh
you know you just slowly he will move
yeah just do that this just don't get
out of the car just you know try to move
forward yeah that's your strategy cat in
life slowly moving forward
um I'm on the New York Times list again
this week
[Applause]
years ago so I think that's actually
meteoric and I'm quite proud of myself
well you should your uh underlying what
the congresswoman said about our society
yeah that people should be proclaiming
the golden opportunities we give to
marginalized people like you the Polish
nobody ever talks about the Polish I
know I just did yeah I appreciate that
yeah thank you thank you it's just
amazing not that she even put out a book
but that she can read one
well you know
you haven't been watching show for seven
years you think all of a sudden he's
just gonna compliment her and not have
some backhanded thing at the end
shame on you yeah no better you should
never be surprised anymore I can also
really really really right
um I agree with Tyrus though the slogan
is so stupid yeah they're like just stop
oil as if that's simple which is why of
course they don't they're not phased by
people who need to get to work because
they're like just don't go if you guys
think yeah stupid though you'd be blown
away by some of the stuff we hear on
natural resources I mean these people
actually think you know it's crazy a
majority of Americans with the national
income they can't afford brand new
electric vehicles and they're just like
you just need to finance it and deal
with it right like you can't do that you
can't force people to do that even if
you made electric vehicles free and we
had 50 of the country elect you can't
plug them in nowhere there's not enough
everyone will be out of power
Jamie plug the one in that shorts
everything out and if you got a little
um and if you've got a little dog he's
gonna just chew right through that yeah
so chew right through all of them
there's just no way too and I get so
pissed off when I'm trying to get to
work and I can't get to work yeah so I
think that if you you really you really
need to pay attention to that people are
like oh who are these people and I can't
get to work and all my life's living
hell I want to listen to them more no
because I've even said that about like
the Christmas tree yes you hate Chris
and I know I don't I love Christmas
books I like to hang out with my family
that is true it was nice to me that's
good all right we gotta move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else